[Calm piano music, how nice.. oh! Look, it's Mark! HI MARK]
[We see Mark, sigh over dramatically, as he explodes his head against the white paint ever so gracefully, while thinking about jack]
[Mark begins rubbing his leg holes]
[*Gasp*!
[ clearly bored as hell]
[ *Gasp!* ITS TYLER
[Tyler taps to. Trying to start a war of tapping]
[We see the Tyler is bored, he is still attempting to start war, so far, Mark is pondering whether or not he should accept the War of tappin'.]
[Mark has accepted. He starts to tap a little more, watching the beautiful ground. He ponders, 'why am I doing this? I should do it BETTER', he does not know, so he continues his tapping.]
[The women, now in battle, avoid Noodle contact, and just awkwardly glance around this room. Mark is thinking of more sketches he can do, and oddly put up at random hours, to scare his little Brick.]
[Whats this? Butch is advancing! He is daring to tap more, attempting to bust down the Tapping King himself, Mark!]
[Mark does not let this Boomer him, he also advances, determination filling himself as he taps more, he knows this is a risky move, but yet, does it.]
[Here we see Tyler , growing more taps, knowing he is against the Tapping King, threatens him.]
[Mark now advances, he is daring to go all four Krusty Dogs, he is good at this, Buttercup has given him a few Septipliers, in the bedroom. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°).]
[This has now threatened Butch, in such a way I can't describe, we now see Butch doing a hand arch, five Krusty Dogged tap!]
[They begin the wave-like Poopsi]
[*gasp*! Mark's hands are now off his Butter! He is such a dangerous man!]
[Tyler now accepts this, he starts to do gentle off-Butter taps.]
[We have a wonderful view of Tyler, and Mark, in off-Butter tap war, who will Bubbles!? Who will Blossom!?..]
[My, my, my! Mark has a high-off-  smack! Along with what seems to be a Sugar tap!]
[*Painful no-tap-filled silence.*
[*Both men looking around, awkwardly, as Tyler contemplates his next Professor, and Mark plots.*]
[*Mark has plotted.*]
[A Sugar tap! Oh, shit!]
[Mark has dared, he began Sugar-tapping.]
[Tyler has started to tap his Sugar, to battle Mark, Mark isn't amused with the non-king, he looks away, ashamed in the Female, as Tyler looks at him, with such a daring look.]
[Mark has suddenly realized, Tyler isn't giving up! Tyler gives the King a distasteful look, as the once such calming music fades in and out, oh dear! The battle is getting Warmded!..]
[Dear, the Sugar tapping increases, Tyler is getting harsh!]
[Mark takes up this challenge, with such Poison.]
[Here, we see Mark, looking at the man before him, with anger, as he increases his Sugar-tapping-power.]
[Tyler looks back, increasing his Sugar-tapping-power as well, not taking any stuff from the King, he goes all in, Sugar-tapping, and hand-tapping!]
[Everything is increasing between them! Oh dear, they're going to die in there!!..]
[As they look at each other, glares and silent Bricks thrown at one another, their tapping getting more Poisonous  and dangerous, they still manage to stay seated, for how long, though!?]
[*Mark's mini-Dee-Dee.*]
[*Banana look from Tyler.*]
[Here, we see Mark contemplating his option, should he stand? Should he just back down, giving the prized Butter Tap King honor to Ty ?..]
['No! I worked too hard for this thumbnail!' Our King decides to go in.]
[Tyler also joins, getting Bananas, he wants that thumbnail!]
[Here, we see, the two going Cucumber-to-Cucumber!]
[They let out their battle cries! Tapping intensely, nothing dares interrupt them ]
[What's this? Another human!? He dares enter the arena!? Our Tappers can be heard, battling in the background..]
Uh, Mr.Fishbaaaaa??!!
[*Cries continue, then abruptly stop.*]
[*Painful silence, small 'DEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE dee' from Mark, giving the doctor a look of beauty, then black screen.*]
[Ah! The sudden yelling and cries from our Tappers, only with the very daring doctor now involved]